if they've never been to Copenhagen
people's primary association with Danish
capital might be the statue of the
little mermaid in the harbor but the
most beautiful sight is the city itself
with its unique seaside location this
year British lifestyle magazine monocle
and its editor-in-chief Tyler Brule
placed Copenhagen at number six in its
ranking of the world's most livable
cities when we look at Copenhagen one of
the things which I think has forced a
bit of a stumble comes back to to
connectivity public transport they've
done a great job of course is is it the
global home of the bicycle bike paths
here almost as wide as street lanes for
cars Copenhagen is one of the world's
most bicycle-friendly cities and cycling
is part of everyday life the city has
more bicycles than residents every
second person right to bike to work here
footrests a traffic light sees the
waiting and tilted trash cans were
designed specially for cyclists
Copenhagen of course continues to
succeed because they have the bicycle
miracle in the city it is just it's so
easy to get from A to B to see it on to
Zed just by going around on two wheels
or potentially three wheels if you have
if you have children
it's an incredibly walkable city but
just over half a million people live
here Copenhagen's moderate-sized makes
it a pretty relaxed metropolis the
cityscape is characterized by
Architecture from the 18th century like
a Malian borg palace for city residents
of the Danish royal family classical
residential and commercial buildings
stand alongside modern constructions
like the opera house new influences are
unmistakable in the restaurant scene too
[Music]
Copenhagen has experienced in the last
five or six years such a boom from a
culinary perspective mean it's really
recognized as probably one of the most
important food cities in the world New
Nordic cuisine began in 2003 when the
restaurant Noma opened here star chef
Rene Redzepi prepared his dishes solely
with regional ingredients Noma was
recognized as the world's best
restaurant four times since then Danish
cooks have been combining Denmark's best
culinary traditions with dishes from
abroad for example at the Royal smooshy
cafe where little works of art are
created on a tiny slice of bread the
smooshy are as handy to eat as sushi and
are reminiscent of smear Brut the Danish
variant of the open-faced sandwich
smooshy are just one Copenhagen success
story what we really like about
Copenhagen is startup means your
restaurant means starting up your own
shop it means launching your own fashion
label doing things with your own hands
and that's one of the great things that
you've seen a lot of people coming back
into the city who are not speculating
they're not looking to build a business
and then just flip it three years later
for some crazy valuation they they
really want to be be part of the urban
fabric
all over the downtown area our little
design shops like henrique vibe scoffs
after studying in London he returned to
Copenhagen who launched his own fashion
label his designs have even been
displayed in museums like New York's
MoMA Copenhagen also stands for design
classics like Ana Jakob Sims furniture
which is still produced today in the
hotel he designed you can even book a
night in the honor Jakob son suite
furnished with original pieces the
capital city of design as Copenhagen
likes to call itself has its share of
planning mistakes of course monocle
magazine says there why Copenhagen only
made it to sixth place on this year's
list of the world's most livable cities
we've seen extraordinary growth within
the city a lot of new development but a
lot of new development which is not very
sympathetic to the rest of the built
environment so quite interesting
buildings architecture away but we see a
lot of buildings which have no
relationship to the street
despite this criticism residents still
regard Copenhagen as Europe's most
pleasant capital with so many people and
music and so colorful so really enjoying
it there's always happy people and in
the summertime here this is a special
place to be
monocle magazine says reducing the 25%
value-added tax in restaurants would be
yet one more way Copenhagen could
improve its already outstanding quality
of life
[Music]